this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
what is a controlled experiment and why
would you want to do one
maybe you have an idea that you think
might explain a situation
this is called a scientific hypothesis
how could you find out if your
hypothesis is correct
well you'd set up a controlled
experiment in which you control or keep
constant
all the factors known as variables
except for the one you want to test
let's design a controlled experiment to
test a fertilizer which claims it makes
plants grow bigger lusher and perhaps
produce more flowers fruit or vegetables
if you wanted to see if the fertilizer
works how would you set up a controlled
experiment to test this claim
first you would get two plants of the
same species let's call them plant a and
plant b
everything about the plants should be
exactly the same including their size
health and age
next you would put each plant in
identical pots with the same amount of
the same kind of dirt or soil
you would water them both the same
amount at the same times
you would also put the plants next to
each other in the same place such as a
window sill so that they're both exposed
to the same amount of sunlight and kept
at the same temperature
it's important that everything is the
same because the purpose of your
experiment is to find out whether or not
the fertilizer works
so what would be different
in this experiment the only difference
is that only plant a would get the
fertilizer
now remember your hypothesis is that
plant a which is getting fertilizer will
grow bigger compared to plant b which
isn't getting any fertilizer
how would you know whether your
hypothesis is correct
you'd know because you'd regularly
measure the plants during the course of
the experiment for example once a week
for a period of three months
you would record these measurements
throughout the experiment
these measurements are your data
at the end of the experiment you would
look at your data and compare the
measurements of plant a which got
fertilizer to plant b which didn't get
fertilizer
as you can see plant a did grow bigger
than plant b
so it appears that the results of this
controlled experiment support your
hypothesis
so let's recap the elements of
experimental design
what were you testing
you were testing to see whether or not
fertilizer promotes plant growth
what was your hypothesis
the hypothesis was that the plant that
got fertilizer would get bigger than the
plant that didn't get fertilizer
what were you measuring
you measured the growth of both plants
how do you know if the results of the
experiment support your hypothesis
well if your hypothesis is true you
would have seen that the plant that got
the fertilizer actually did get bigger
than the plant that didn't get any
fertilizer
the variable you were testing in this
case the fertilizer is called the
independent variable and the thing you
were observing measuring and expecting
to change because of that independent
variable was plant growth
in this experiment plant growth is the
dependent variable
we'll go over independent and dependent
variables in more detail in another
video
[Music]